welcome back to CBS mornings we are just
two days away from the kickoff of this
year's World Cup in Qatar and on the
surface the stadiums are highly
impressive the country one of the
richest in the world has spared no
expense in creating state-of-the-art
facilities to host the competition
except it seems when it comes to the
workers who actually built them many
migrants are forced to live in squalor
Holly Williams spoke to some of those
workers and she's here with us right now
Holly good morning welcome hey Nate well
this world cup has always been
controversial firstly the weather is so
hot in Qatar they've had to switch the
competition from this summer to the
winter recently the former president of
FIFA that soccer's governing body said
it was a mistake to give the World Cup
to Qatar but for many people the biggest
issue is qatar's human rights record
they went wild in Qatar 12 years ago
when they heard their country had won
the right to host the World Cup a shake
from the country's ruling family
promised it would be a success thank you
for giving Qatar a chance
and we will not let you down
you will be proud of us a Middle Eastern
nation roughly the size of Connecticut
qatar's one of the wealthiest countries
in the world
it's poured more than 200 billion
dollars into eight state-of-the-art
air-conditioned soccer stadiums and all
the other infrastructure to host over a
million Spectators
but to build it qatars relied on an army
of Migrant workers mostly from South
Asia and Africa toiling in temperatures
of up to 120 degrees and living in
crowded squalid camps like this one
they're like anyone else in the world
you want to have a better life than your
parents you want your children to go to
college to have a better life than you
so you're desperate for any opportunity
so you have a World Cup dependent on
migrant workers because they're cheap
and Michael workers are cheap because
they're being exploited most of the
country founded equidim an organization
that investigates labor abuses he says
he was arrested in Qatar while
researching conditions there including
forced labor workers going unpaid for
months at a time and unsafe work sites
with deadly results
it's very hard to give an exact figure I
would suspect it's actually in the
hundreds I think hundreds of workers
have died to make this world cup
possible sometimes uh Imran Khan comes
from Bangladesh and claims he worked
shifts of up to 48 hours straight on
buildings including loose sale Stadium
where the World Cup final will be held I
have noticed as a worker have no choice
Norris not just he told us he was paid
about 350 a month half of what he was
originally promised if I'm making
complaint against company they just said
go back
foreign
left his home in Nepal to build roads in
Qatar sending money back to his family
before he was killed in an accident last
year
his widow Miller told us her family
received no compensation just her
husband's body they've now fallen deeper
into poverty she says and sometimes
can't afford food
labor rights groups want Qatar to set up
a fund of around half a billion dollars
to compensate injured and unpaid workers
and the families of those killed this
month Qatar rejected that suggestion as
a publicity stunt it's really
conflicting and that I think is also
makes you very upset
knowing that we're going to watch our
teams that we love play and at the same
time this is all made possible because
of this incredible exploitation
I know when you think about that
exploitation I think is a word there
it's hard doing anything to address any
of these these claims yeah also Gail um
Qatar says that it is paying back unpaid
wages and it has actually made some
pretty significant changes including
raising the minimum wage and allowing
migrant workers to switch jobs without
their employers permission but human
rights groups say those changes just
don't go far enough and actually in many
cases aren't even being enforced
Hollywood a report like this even be
shown in Qatar like would they block
this would the sensor stop it that's
yeah that's such a good question I don't
know the answer to it I guess when you
go to cartel what really strikes you is
just the kind of imbalance in power
between really tiny country incredibly
wealthy just a few hundred thousand
citizens and then these hundreds of
thousands or even millions of Migrant
workers that gap between the extremely
wealthy and those who are struggling
financially yeah there's so many
questions about how they even got it to
begin with and that raises that's a
whole nother issue and you've got
another report coming up on Monday we do
yeah Holly thank you so much